previously on raft why the captain is
that what we decided
have you ever won a wheel thing ever
there's a rock nice rock avoidance not
captain ice rock avoidance not first
mate does that mean i am first wait i
called you first mate wade oh my
captain baby i'm two planks short of a
paddle we are going to sacrifice some of
the ship yeah
wait wait wait
this is a big island and there's a big
bird i see a man a banana
i've been out of a [ __ ] and or horse oh
my god it's aborts
the dick bird not what you deserved i
say underwater where no one can hear
the rp rolls in this raft are real loose
okay in a whisper voice only you can
hear i'll kill you i ran the whole
island expedition this shit's exhausting
i don't want to be capped anymore who is
captain
holy [ __ ] i won a wheel thing you
[ __ ] are about second mate
[Laughter]
well captain your quarters are
officially cleaned out i got my my stuff
out of your little cabinet in there so
yeah it's all
it's all you now it's all that's your
little oh and i will open these three
decorative packages all right okay
captain would you like me to do captain
valiantly captain should you should i
keep
making
beats uh
i trust your judgment on that all right
kim oh deferring to the expert
what is our food situation oh good
actually
excellent i'm starving to death we
learned a real pirate flag
whoa someone make the new flag all right
let's see what it is yes sir
[Music]
i've already made the flag captain i
shall replace the flag on top of the
captain's
beautifully done look at that almost
visible jolly roger on the flag i
painted it with my own feces and spit
that's pretty five mate you're almost
there oh get that
i appreciate that captain that's very
generous of you yeah i made a calendar
that sounds like a waste of resources
captain 1.25 yeah
because i like numbers numbers make me
feel richer than i am ah you want
currency do you captain mayhaps my
pockets would be
loinful
what wow
fascinating captain
sorry
what a language you just busted out sir
thank you i put a navigational flag near
the sale for you captain for your
convenience uh wait uh captain now is my
navigational sale i put the navigational
sale there for you captain uh it's just
an idea that i had mates
captain i've also begun roasting
potatoes so that we will be able to
feast whenever we want that's a waste of
wood captain healing credit made me
happy actually roasting potatoes
is just saying uh roasted potatoes is a
waste of nothing we have a limited
amount of wood
and lots of wood no we have a lot of
detergent whether it's a waste or not do
we have butter uh yeah no not yet just
light waste uh captain if you want i can
spit on it for you so it's kind of juicy
not a waste i could spit it on it if you
want no the first maid gets to spit on
it sir
you know you can stab those and and get
chicken legs why would i do that fly
check what do we need at the moment
uh i'm not smart enough to know captain
we're pretty much rocking and rolling
captain everything's looking pretty hot
honestly it would be nice to make a
cooking pot that would be the or a big
grill actually the big grill should be
the next thing we make that was just
ahead about me o'clock
oh neat uh
excellent 1.05 mate
thank you the clock actually is pretty
cool that's that's neat
uh paddler raft ahead
who's the paddler you're the best i'm
the paddler here
oh kevin
no i had nothing to say i just wanted to
say your beautiful name okay
oh god i might need another paddle can
you get that scrubby to make me another
paddle uh
not quite first mate another paddle
i'm not quite uh it depends how fast the
paddle's made i don't wanna captain
could you turn the sail toward the thing
you want me to go towards i feel like
i'm fighting in the airplane
the captain had to make himself would
you like the honor of looting the raft
or shall i do it
uh go for it raft looted sir hey uh
dabbing he's going down got him i got a
present in my hands now i'm gonna open
it
damn it nice try kevin
land ho i believe straight ahead but i
have to look at the horizon weirdly to
see it
kind of curvy we're kind of all cat
canty wumpus captain hi i think the wind
is blueing us away i shall paddle
excellent work i think we're headed
right towards it aren't we
no yes oh
kind of i feel like this this this sail
is useless
yeah well wham
new sail
yep that's what i do first date again
and whispered voice only you can hear of
actual first mate i only said that so
you'd actually listen and cooperate good
work almost first mate you'll be
promoted yet all right [ __ ] you ah the
potato on first mate i require some spit
yes on it
you're welcome captain would you like
more space
sir
yes
thank you that was really juicy captain
and i a little bit regret doing that in
real life just expect i don't feel very
satisfied after eating it well you only
had one you can have as many potatoes as
you desire trading post look at this
brilliant navigation you've done captain
i can't believe you why not why can't
you believe me it's astonishing you
astonish me sir
it should not be astonishing that i am
successful it's not astonishing that you
are it's astonishing how you do it
mind-boggling even
why do i feel like there's a lot more
undertone to my captainship than
previous captains hmm uh
i don't even know what that means what
are you talking about captain it's kind
of like undercurrent but it's
an attempt to undermine
ah i can't understand your deep thoughts
captain they go over me
yeah they're saying words but they're so
complicated oh captain it's like you're
in my head you keep opening the exact
thing i'm trying to access oh that's not
gavin that's me but thank you oh
you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
was it the shark look out
hey the sharks here oh
all right all right let's kill it so we
can get some more medals i don't want to
oh oh i want to i order you to fight the
shark
i'm tired don't care in the water fight
the shark i'm making bricks
i'll be bait captain
hi
well you've always been my favorite all
right i'm getting in the water gavin
i'm in the water oh shark it's uh really
dividing our hunting efforts right now i
have to say oh boy here we go all right
you're really ruining this whole thing
oh and you did it in a place where no
one could help i'm not doing you i'm
helping i'm helping i'm killing it
stab
it's dead i killed it you just hit it
like once after the captain so bravely
did so much
times
the captain killed the shark you just
tried to steal who killed the shark
first mates bob
what
he wasn't even arguing that the captain
uh just respects uh my valiant ah
you discovered that cooked potatoes give
way more food yeah it's almost like
someone was trying to say that yeah well
cabin i'll stop uh the first mate from
sabotaging our food efforts from here on
out don't you worry about thing cap hey
can you put some planks on one of those
grills there flunky
is the captain flunky
no sir good answer the captain is
flunkette if anything hmm i
which is a term of endearment if you
know anything about terms and endearing
not that i'm questioning your knowing
captain i'm just saying that you know i
would
wouldn't be surprised if you didn't know
some words just
i was busy succeeding where you all fail
you are succeeding captain you're such a
success you're a succeeder
not surprisingly laughed and or smiled
while saying that but you're right just
thinking you're the most special
man i've ever known
i
why do you say i like that that's not
how pirates say that that's really
disconcerting exactly how pirates say
that tell the captain how pirates talk
uh well i'm just i'm not saying you're
not a captain i'm just saying i am
a pirate i've been a pirate longer than
you have and it just feels like i i mean
that's just a fact this is a fact you
know that that's doubt man that's how
determined the facts
well no that's that's not great you're a
captain
yeah that's really not just because your
captain doesn't mean that you're god of
the universe i mean just take it easy
captain ship is not as good as i thought
it would be i mean
you know you have the ability to like
give orders and stuff i order you to be
better to the captain oh
captain
you want me to suck your dick
i love the way you say i like that it's
my favorite kevmar water production has
been doubled
that's pretty neat that's pretty neat
captain i found
toast
dose presents for you bro
i don't know why that voice just came
out of me like that's my favorite
favorite pirate voice
ghost presents for you bro
bro
i freaking love you bro yo ho and we are
all bros yoho bro
and a bottle of
kombucha
i hereby declare the next piracy we have
for captainship must be from los angeles
specifically santa monica ah
the californian
reign what are you even doing here
captain
like what are you even doing here
captain please don't whoa
there's another again
down to ventura
[Laughter]
i think somebody here might be a comedic
genius i gotta be honest it might be
pretty good i gotta be humpty it's a bit
charmed nice
say it louder say it louder yeah
i'm still not getting
[Music]
that's great captain that's great good
job captain bro i [ __ ] love you all
right
i like the best captain making dramatic
inventory choices captain's gotta be
honest
captain's going for the boar
good work capture yeah i've modified
your quarters
in a good way or a bad power i've
modified them a bad wire bar
captain almost forgot he was about to
fight the bar
the board did not forget
gavin the boar is stronger than you
oh captain got impaled captain i believe
in you the boar is not stronger than you
you ever will
you off the will of five bores at least
and he only has the will of one board
because of how numbers work you're will
arnett and he's will forte that's the
different types of wielding
see see how much will you are have yes
dude
where there's
a captain wade knew ye could do it hey
bob first mate look what i've done to
the gavin's quarters
yeah i mean nice nice it's functional
it's functional go try it out cool
that's cool it's functional
all right
another bar
uh there's palm trees over here
what not [ __ ] on the raft
are you using it
are you close
anyway
uh
um captain your quarters are
most excellent
well most [ __ ]
one
all right all right captain alright
the board it impaled me do we have
copper yeah there should be some copper
somewhere that can be smelted
it's not smelt
[Music]
okay palm trees to the port side of
where we docked
just walks right by them
i'm not like questioning you captain but
are you sure even more
free wood free real estate
well well honestly we're not really
hurting for planks anymore
we will be
yeah i mean probably but don't have more
i guess i am going as commanded uh make
sure you go listen to distractible it's
not related to this but we're all on it
and it's a podcast it is related to this
if they like this if all the people
watching this want more of us talking
and bullshitting you'll get all the talk
and [ __ ] that you want
indistractible go listen it's free
people think it costs money it does not
why do people think it's awesome i'm the
best everyone knows it that's what i you
know i don't understand is like people
were like oh my
podcast
it's the same thing we do here except
more structure
so you don't have to watch anything that
you don't give a [ __ ] about if you're
just here for us talking [ __ ] yeah
don't you like us if you hate us
you wouldn't watch it so if you don't
watch it you must hate us
if you like us you'll listen if you hate
us you'll listen to watch us fail
anyway link's in the description spotify
itunes all the different things i'll be
returning with metal ore and hopefully
another blowfish captain can i request
toothpaste if you're at the store oh no
i don't have i don't have stone teeth
being [ __ ] is part of the job
i don't mind if my teeth are [ __ ] i just
i i don't like the taste you know of
[ __ ]
i mean
yeah uh yeah i don't really like it
either guys do you like the taste of
[ __ ] captain honest question no
judgments
uh for anecdotal reasons yes what's the
anecdote what are the yeah what are the
antidotes that's for you to decide and
me to not know it sounds like you could
tell us because they're just anecdotal
so yeah seriously
drowning also acquired hang on captain
knees oh it sounds like captain's really
changing the subject here yeah captain
you don't have to be afraid be yourself
uh
yeah sure why not
okay so what is it
sure this was a useless construction
that i made oh
what a waste of resources if i ever
heard one it really was captain doesn't
like that i said all of the previous
three sentences in a hush voice and no
one else could hear oh gotten just fine
with everything captain i'm harvesting a
lot of trees don't worry everything's
fine
i didn't know we could retcon like that
captain didn't either but captain
doesn't make the rules except for when
he does
oh captain really wanted that blowfish
that didn't exist i mean
what
nothing i'm under water in a hushed
police
[Laughter]
real question is how long can we be
entertaining playing this game
you watching why what about this is good
for you i don't know
what it means good game tell us after
you like subscribe and comment other
things below
no don't like comment and subscribe on
on this go listen to distractible on
spotify or you're all right you're right
favorite podcast
what
there's a cave here with dirt who's the
shovel
you had the shovel where did nope it was
thrown out and stolen by one of you two
no no no that might mean that i might
know who might have the shovel then oh
it's a mystery that will never be solved
oh if anyone has a shovel if they want
to go to the island and dig up the dirt
that'd be fine but we're not gonna give
the captain if the shovel were to appear
in a storage box the captain wouldn't
ask questions
captain offering shovel amnesty right
now double amnesty is offered right
double amnesty well hey found the shovel
in this
box i knew it was you you little [ __ ]
nah just kidding where is it captain do
you see it in a box
your eyes are deceiving you captain i
say all in a hushed voice
damn it
do you have wood captain
oh ooh not much where do you need it um
i i have 68 planks holy
[ __ ]
i've harvested every tree in existence
good god man you should be captain
there were a lot of tr you know i've
heard that before
you are
someone very round once told me that i
should be captain yes i've never seen
someone with such commanding wood except
for the captain me i'm how much would
you got gavin
more than you how much well he's got you
there none now i put it all on the
things
captain refilled
and recycled like a responsible captain
should
i've got so much wood i couldn't even
put it all in the things
the things can't hold my wood the
captain had already filled them are you
saying you're better at filling than the
captain i'm the master of filler he
might be actually veto
change well who needs what
there you go buddy thank you
oh more storage
thank god i'm so full of everything
i need
plastic and okay that's that and then
bam and then uh wham
all right you got you guys like my pile
of logs yes that i thought was wood
storage but it turns out isn't it's just
a pile of vlogs wait what it really is
just a pile of vlogs
please
how do we craft your motivational quote
captain
with item nails
i know where nails is
captain don't worry i'm posting your
motivational quote on the side of your
on the side of your chambers
excellent
well there was already a motivational
quote within the chambers that's the
same motivational quota this one's for
you and the one insides for me
and without
but what about this without oh wow uh
planketh the sharkest meter
what nice we have no planks on our
grills
wham all right we need a battery for
that
and batteries going in
yeah you need three antennas for that to
do anything just to let you know
if you look on if you look on the bottom
you'll see little wires numbered one two
and three
three antennae for the navigational
computer
voice that you both can hear he's right
you know thanks captain thanks captain
hi uh no meat is cooking right now
ah well
whose job is that then i think you're
since you asked and it was
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i'm tucked by surprise i am it's how i
maintain my brand i stay unpredictable
by being an idiot requires higher
altitude this is we need higher altitude
for any of the stork i'm taking it away
it's our survival journey i'm taking it
away
have we got enough copper and or metal
for everything no
oh captain good cause captain's gonna
need a new scrapper grabber and a new
pokey stick soon i've got a fishing rod
capped and i shall commence with the
fissioning did anyone check the trading
post we don't have any [ __ ] we can trade
so wait a minute i know how to do this
oh
i know how to do this why are you saying
it like that i know how to do this
whisper tone i can hear oh i know how to
do this
don't well if you can get stuff get me
some give me some bait but watch this
bam
it's a trash can
whoa we can make trash cubes i'll put
the firewood rack in there
that's
trash it up i trashed it
wait
wait oh my gosh
and which one is the trash
what captain captain
they're not captain captain
hi
dude that's
sick dude thanks why did you look at me
just to eat a compete
why what's wrong with it
nothing i just
resisted the why yeah why don't you go
in your quarters for a bit you look
tired
oh uh all right
that's uh that's a cool trash can you've
got there it doesn't make the trash
cubes we need but
oh hi captain oh hi i like when people
watch when i [ __ ]
[Music]
oh hey oh no hey just fishing over here
don't worry just eating beets
just not watching as i hey there's a
toilet potatoes in my inventory so you
should eat
those that's a good deal just come here
and i'll feed you
[Music]
uh crouch crouch
good like that good nice open
ah
here comes the choo choo
one whole potato thank you look i'm
rationing okay here
in a whisper tone that only the cat can
hear
that's the last of our food don't tell
the idiot excellent
i'm just glad we have plenty of food to
keep us alive uh would anyone like baked
potatoes
a friend smart smartest man on the ship
other than the captain of myself yes
would you like some potatoes no
thank you
my god we need more wood
i have i put so much wood in the you
know what it's all in my inventory
actually what do you need have some wood
didn't i give you like a whole stack of
wood i would love that if that's if
there's a thing you can do didn't i
already do that you did but i i made an
antenna and a thing and it got to pretty
bizarre oh camera spear bro can we make
captain a new spear uh probably that's a
first mate job if ever i heard it oh
truly it is a first i agree so whoever
delivers one must be my first mate
yeah no i don't even want it i'm on that
oh thank you first mate
now the shark dies so the captain may
eat good again i feel like
maybe we should be sailing
yeah i feel like we should be sleeping
do we need more
copper and [ __ ] oh yeah no we do need to
sort of harvest the waters don't we
captain the shark
i can't help you because i'm fishing and
that's important too but look out
captain look out hi hi
captain look out captain it's the shark
okay oh captain he's eating us
shark's dead all right let me harvest
that let me harvest that i'm going to
cook it anyway let me harvest the rest
of it
okay well i got one
shark head and you got all the meat uh i
feel like if i'm in charge of cooking
i'd like here third oh okay thank you
good did this trash can not make a trash
cube
it does i can tell you that doesn't do
what you think these bird nests
of things it does not make crash cubes
there's a specific thing that's powered
by a battery that compresses trash into
trash cubes and there's specific stuff
that can be compressed into the kind of
trash cube that you can trade at the
close
[Music]
we ain't there yet we got a lot of
splorin to do all right all right all
right
ow oh hey i found a blowfish
oh where
uh um
it's really more of a cloud fish at the
moment damn it
also we have no planks on the grills
well somebody should have a whole stack
of planks i used them don't worry
captain i'm doing all the right stuff i
know where to get planks
oh why are you destroying me
i needed one blank
you're going to see why
what happened to all the vine goo you
were the one i never touched it who took
the vine
there was so much vinegar in here
i don't see any i feel like that's a
hundred percent on you friend
i'm just saying there's a seaweed needs
to be cooked i put seaweed in it to make
vine goo to make a thousand people
haven't made a water bottle captain
would love some good vine goo water
bottle why do you need a water bottle
better than to bring
a cup of water take a watermelon with
you it's a water
melon
animals because we want to live in a
society we live in a society you wha
watermelon is delicious watermelons
don't create a society they kind of die
create a society agrarian culture is not
not anymore look my bros my bros we're
fighting and why why are we fighting
because you're wrong and i hate it
all right
well i've made something that you guys
are going to love but you know i don't
even know if i'm going to welcome you
into it i i question
you to welcome us
i know you're going to love it because i
love it and i want you to allow us to be
a part of it
i think i will allow you to be a part of
it because
that's how much i love you how much
specifically do you love me
i love you so much you're going to get
the first thing of it okay that's
sounding increasingly threatening
you're going to receive it do i have a
choice in the matter
no
you say it's an enema of the state
link 182 times if it is
are you hedonism but
maybe
[Laughter]
[Music]
look i don't know man i don't know look
it's it's not it's not what you think
it's not what you think am i
oh
my god look at this thing go
get out of there
freaking burgers
captain i'm becoming increasingly
concerned about what this oh my god
i'm very concerned you guys are going to
love this
sounds very threatening
oh no i need one more thing
[ __ ] up don't forget captain's helpful
tips don't drown yeah i think that shark
might be back hey sharks back that's fun
i order it not to be back
sharks gone weird
that's a good order captain excellent
order there's a lot going on on the boat
is it good on the boat or bad on the oh
my god the island is foggy for me is it
foggy out is it foggy or am i foggy oh
it's foggy it's funny what do you think
it's funky okay good i'm gonna just i'm
gonna
come on it come on in i'm gonna come on
yeah you would you would
i am we have metal and copper i have
five metal and three copper on me which
is not a lot
not a lot captain where are my fellow
shipmates at i'm so ready for you
looking for a nice blow under the sea oh
i've got a blow for you
i don't know
no that's that's the tone i'm not liking
that's the thing guys it's raining in
the ocean
i think we're going to hell
it was harsh
i think the devil is upon us
also i have a whole lot of seaweed
don't you dare okay i'll put the seaweed
back
no i'm sorry
i thought i was just helping i didn't
know what the is that a rule that i'm
unaware of
don't you dare dare help with the
seaweed i'm trying i didn't dare i would
never dare don't i don't dare you dare
how dare you you're a player of truth or
truth i see oh my god guys i just
harvested so much seaweed and it's all
just boxes in the ocean because my
pockets were full
no seaweed are you not to waste the
seaweed i i'm not i'm not i didn't
sounds like you're wasting the seaweed
no i'm just upset about it
check this out
yes
it's just
seaweed
we're out of planks
don't worry i got some planks
which in this economy is pretty good
captain i have such a thirst
uh
please spit in me mouth i have something
for you
when you get here i'm limping my way
back because i limp when i'm thirsty
calm down i'm coming oh i've got
something
oh you stay right there stay right there
come here come here come here i want to
show you something am i allowed to drink
bob get here get
no no no you're not allowed to drink
anything yeah why would you be allowed
to drink anything
i'm trying to get into you guys
not be drinking
all right you wait wait are you ready
are you ready
okay
here
made you smoothies
i can't hold it because i'm so dead
getting dying i wanted to make a toast
you drink
son of a
please can i drink it yet no i have to
make a toast there's another one no hold
on
toast already hold on there's another
smoothie ready i'm gonna give it to the
cabin then he's gonna be in front of you
hold on
here
hold on
all right do not drink this immediately
all right
i'd like to make a toast
wait there's a seagull wait wait wait
all right
no i killed it i killed it okay
all right i'm ready here we go
i would like to make a toast to the
finest crew on the seven seas led by the
most noble
the most anxious
the most handsome incredible
bountiful courageous motivational
captain we have ever had the honor
of serving underneath may all other
ships
be embarrassed
and beg for mercy when they realize how
unimportant their adventures are
compared to ours
and with that i'll turn it over to the
captain to say a few words
i thank you
that's very very kind more slowly than i
would have thought captain don't worry
yourself about it
uh the surprise i have at drinking such
a fine beverage among such
you as more than i ever could have
expected so
uh thank you and uh bottoms up there's a
shirt
before i drink my smoothie it's fine
it's fine this is fine oh i drank mine
oh okay well you can drink now yes of
course
it's not gonna be cold yeah it's gonna
melt
ah
it does not immediately cure my thirst i
forgot how that works all right shall we
set sail captain
hi i'm feeling better captain
good
cool oh are you the captain i'm supposed
to say good
good that's good
good
i smell something in the air could it be
no it couldn't be an end to my captain's
ship already right might be
might just be
smells like teen spirit is it is it time
for me to spin the wheel of captain
i believe it's the captain's choice
you haven't shy spin it hi you know
we've had a good run why not spinning
well you can see what it was
accidentally clicked out of the pop-up
unless you declare this invalid yeah i
think we should re-spin i don't know if
that can really count all right that's
fair
what was the result that's fair oh i see
wait why wouldn't that count
no it counts but i don't want to be camp
david uh
i don't want to be captain you're a
captain dude dad you're captain dad dude
you're dude you're a dude
whoa
ah my brain mark you're a family
engineer for this stint all right you
would make another scrap hook
scrap hooks
probably yeah uh papa papa papa
former dad me who doesn't need one while
we'll have wow
must be that smoothie i drank two of
them they're very strong
does anyone have plastic i need one more
go on for it oh [ __ ]
hey the shark's there
i stabbed it in the mouth and it didn't
actually bite i made armored things so
that our our
thing will permanently be armored
there you are sir
armored shall we set sail captain
first mate wade
engineer mark yeah i like that title
let's get the [ __ ] out of here it's
really disorienting going from captain
to not captain yeah shut your mouth hole
yeah
actually captains feel pretty lazy
though first mate wade will you um like
take over captainage
do captain stuff i'm sleeping right
gonna die in starvation uh that's not
captain stuff literally surrounded by
food there first mate ah ate it all no
food left for anyone else just like the
captain should all right i'll see if i
can engineer you up some more
captain is trying to cook fish on the
smelters that's fine
hmm good work ken good working captain
are you captain i'm the captain you're
the first mate you're doing stuff but it
doesn't change your title do i have two
captains no you have a captain and a
first mate who you will address as
stinky
stinky
you'll address this both the stinky or
just me
wade's name is stinky now and my name is
captain the captain
hi captain the captain captain captain
now that bob is the captain and he's
declared stinky the first mate what will
they do in the next episode of
raft
you hear something kevin
like a narrator or some [ __ ] and they're
already at each other's throats no one
knows who's in charge the engineer is
actively sabotaging the ship but the
others do not know
will they discover the plots and
explosive cities planted all over the
raft or will they be doomed to sink to
the bottom of the sea in a fireball of
death
uh
only only viewers can hear the narrator
we have no idea what just happened oh
tune in next week to find out
[Music]
[Music]
foreign